hello everyone welcome hello welcome to
simulation how are you guys doing good
yeah whoo there's that energy let's get
a little bit a good energy in here yeah
we we love the battery this is an
amazing venue and you guys are really
great people we know lots of people that
are members at the battery so this is a
privilege and an honor to be here right
now
and featuring a show here have any of
you been to one of the simulation live
events before yeah we have a couple yeah
yeah but mostly no okay so so simulation
is a daily show and live event series we
feature some of the greatest scientists
entrepreneurs technologists educators of
our time and we really love the power of
really thought-provoking questions and
how are we gonna guide the future of
humanity
and so we see you know sports stadiums
filled with 22 football players and
we're like how about we fill it with
curious intellectuals to sound like fun
yeah yeah let's see if we can get there
and do that so that's a little bit about
us so the guests are you guys excited
for a dr. Aubrey de Grey yeah yeah we're
really excited for Aubrey yes yes he's
an author biomedical gerontologist he's
a chief science officer at sends the
strategies for engineered negligible
senescence
he's also the VP of New Age discovery
therapeutics and he we are really
excited to feature him we're gonna be
talking about rejuvenative rejuvenative
medicine and the roadmap to end aging so
without further ado introducing dr.
Aubrey de Grey
okay Aubrey thank you for joining us
this is I think that's a show number
four or five together we've done a
couple shows together yeah and it's been
a pleasure every single time I always
learn more and more about your work and
about kind of where we stand on this
major goal that that you call it the Pro
aging trance that everybody thinks that
that aging is totally okay and yeah
having a nice chat with some of your
friends over dinner just now about that
you know one has to one must have to
work really hard to persuade myself that
aging is a blessing in disguise
I mean honestly and you're working on
Regina rejuvenated medicine to end Aging
and you have been for quite a while this
is now how many decades in are you well
I see I switched from baby to be the
scientist to being a biologist something
like 22 23 years ago I think you know we
could say that I was I've been working
in you know actively and actually you
know sponsoring research and so on for
about 15 years it's a long time it's
almost as long as I've been alive yeah I
I should have said I'm I'm Alan sake and
I host the show and Aubrey is alas he's
saying here he's done this 23 years and
switching from computer science which
also gives you a very interesting sort
of spin and take on understanding things
yes and you say that the aging is not a
consequence of biology but rather
physics well okay yes let's talk about
that soaked people the fundamental
problem that I think helps people to
maintain this ridiculous Pro aging trial
if they continue to believe that they do
the mystery you know there's some kind
of utterly an enigmatic phenomenon that
nobody understands Oh which is complete
nonsense and the way that the reason I
make this I make this point about
physics and in particular the reason I
emphasize that ageing of a living
organism is pretty much
indistinguishable from ageing of a
simple in element machine like a car or
an airplane is to demystify it you know
to emphasize that decay is something
that naturally occurs as a result of the
normal functioning of any machine that
has moving parts but naturally is not is
not the same as inevitably so in just
the same way that we can compensate for
the accumulation of damage in a car an
airplane by periodic comprehensive
preventative maintenance
similarly we have absolutely no reason
to doubt that we can do the same thing
for the human body it's just that it's
harder because the human body is more
complicated and of course the natural
reaction to that is to say well yeah I
mean that if the point isn't it the
human body astronomically more
complicated therefore this hypothetical
preventative maintenance is
astronomically more complicated
therefore we might as well forget it
because we weren't actually ever be able
to do it but that turned out not to be
true when you look at the detail from
that where everything that we do at
Stan's Research Foundation has come from
in there's a hundred thousand people
that die per day for aging that's this
is right it's actually around about a
hundred and ten thousand now I mean
actually that's a remarkable thing so
the first time I did those numbers were
at least fifteen years ago that's a
little longer and yeah I came out a row
number pretty much exactly around
two-thirds of all deaths worldwide being
due to aging in other words being due to
cause is that pretty much never hit
people who are in
adulthood and you know that's shocking
and of course it's even more shocking if
you restrict yourself to the
industrialized world you're up around 85
or 90 percent but what's even more
important that to me is that over the
past 15 years those numbers have been
shifting upwards fast so it's almost up
around three-quarters of all deaths now
it's well over 70 percent it's
astounding you know at this point into
the most recent statistics there isn't a
single country in the whole world whose
average lifespan is below 50 even like
sub-saharan Africa if you exclude suppli
in Africa then it's the bottom one is
over 60 so you know eating is not just a
first world problem absolutely not you
you're also very good at making the
content relatable you and as this
happens you become a professional or
what you do 23 years now you you you
make this very clear that metabolism
causes damage which causes pathology
over time and you make this analogy to
the vehicle tweaking a vehicle over time
and that that repair process can keep a
vehicle operating longer and so what are
sort of the the tweaks that we're
working on internally for our own bodies
yeah yeah thank you I mean you're quite
right then I think this is this is
something that I've gravitated to as an
extremely effective way of helping
people to understand what's going on
here dividing the process of aging into
two processes firstly the creation of
damage as a consequence of the machines
normal operation whether it's the human
body or whether it's and secondly the
decline in function of the machine that
results from having more damage than the
machine is set up to tolerate there's
always a certain finite amount of damage
that the machine is set up to Toller
whether by human design in the case of
Karla whatever or whether by evolution
but it's a fine amount and once you get
beyond that thing it's got start to go
downhill so nobody into those who cut it
with helps a lot it helped especially in
order to explain that preventative
maintenance really is all we need it
really does give us the ability to keep
the level of damage below that threshold
so that we never get the decline in
function that we would normally see and
then of course the specifics matter of
course should not necessarily matter to
you guys in the same way that you don't
really care exactly what your car
mechanic does when you take your car in
right you just at the same time because
we can't do it yet you kind of do want
to know a little bit about the details
because you won't know how realistic it
is that will actually get them working
fairly soon
so yeah I mean it's things like stem
cell therapies various uses of gene
therapies to repair and augment the
genetic capacity of ourselves to repair
themselves or to kill themselves when
they see one with when they're not
wanted that's actually important part
then immune therapies tweaking and
optimizing the immune system to work
better against things that it already
works a little bit against but not well
enough
I can says you know these are the kind
of things that we do but the ultimate
goal here the ultimate like 40,000 foot
level is all about restoring the
structure of the body to how it was at
an earlier age structure at the
molecular level and at the cellular
level if we can do that then kind of by
definition we will restore function at
the same time because at the end of the
day however complicated a machine is and
however clearly we understand the way
that it works its function is determined
by its structure
okay what do I say that we've even
flatly telling no not
oh I'm just on a road map to end aging
there's nothing challenged there there's
okay so so we have we have okay the way
we feel when we're very young we feel
like we can take on the world
and then these sort of ailments occur to
us over time and then it's wee-bey PFL
auburn you still feel like you're 15
sometimes okay we take we take
technologies like stem cell therapy and
gene therapy and we how do we scan the
body to figure out where the pathology
is occurring a really important question
for a reason that's a little bit
counterintuitive it's probably not going
to be very important to do scanning and
the reason it's not is because we all
have the same kind of damage there is no
scattering curative is because of course
we're all familiar with the fact that
different people in old age get
different problems you know some people
do have cancer some people does but it
turns out that if you take into account
if you start from what I just told you
about how these problems only emerge
when you've got more than a particular
threshold tolerable amount and
particular type of damage or a range of
times then it turns out that this this
variety in in what goes wrong with us is
kind of an exaggerated image of what's
really going on what's really going on
is that we're all accumulating the exact
same types of damage every one of us all
the time before were born even but
there's small differences just
all differences in the rate at which
we're accumulating different types of
damage so some of them get to an
intolerable point a little bits in
another etcetera right now what that
means of course is that if we're
attacking the damage this precursors
which is what we're doing right here
with preventative maintenance and not
attacking the consequences of the damage
the actual late-life pathologies then we
don't need to worry about those
differences I mean the worst that can
happen is that we might end up giving
people a damage repair therapy twice as
often as they might need it think is
about right so in there won't have any
negative consequences in experimental
right you have to get to a point where
you understand the safety but yes I'm
absolutely certain that it will be easy
to get to a point where the what's
called the therapeutic index of these
therapies is easily wide enough that the
one we took the problem yeah that it'll
be totally fine because I'll be totally
fine it'll probably be a lot cheaper and
more efficient than just to give
everybody their time to talk okay so so
then in this matter what age
approximately so that comes down to the
question of the fact that these
therapies bona fide rejuvenation that
will take people back to an earlier
biological age than what they were
before so what that means is that it
makes no more sense to apply these
therapies to 20-year old than it would
to take a brand-new car into the garage
after a year and it's gonna be a long
time before the damage does gets to the
point where there's enough to repair
that actually you know justifies doing
it plus we have second to account
something that does not apply with cars
and I believe that we're still learning
how to do this and we will carry on
perfecting these therapies not only in
terms of cost but also convenience
comprehensiveness safety of thought um
for a long long time so that means that
the trade-off will be that it makes
sense to went to a middle-age yes you'll
have more damage to repair but that's
okay what if it won't be bad for you yet
and also the scientists will have had
all
time to make the therapy that much
better before they at Lund a year I see
this animation of this visual of the age
slowly increasing and damaged slowly
accumulating and then getting a breed
agree to come over and and bring my
damage down in my age biological age
back down and that's okay so this is
around middle age this one will be 50
okay yeah I mean very little goes wrong
with you until you're 50 badly wrong I
mean of course of course it's perfectly
fine to apply these therapies earlier if
you happen to be an unlucky person but
no forty so on and then let's maybe dive
a bit into the nitty gritty nuance of
the biology and physics so there are a
certain amount of strategies at Sens
foundation and maybe you talk to us
about how you're actually so I think
it's because the human body is so
ridiculously complicated we do
unquestionably have a large number of
different types of damage that
accumulate in the body but that isn't
necessarily a problem and I would say
the single biggest breakthrough that I
ever made scientifically back in 2000
was to appreciate to realize that the
even though there's so many different
types of damage they can be classified
we can make a kind of taxonomy of damage
and in particular that we can group them
into a very manageable number of
categories just seven categories the
utility of this classification is not
immediately obvious but that may explain
what it is the utility is it determined
it defines the strategies for
intervention so for each category within
each category there may be lots and lots
of different examples of types of damage
but all of them can be addressed can be
repaired in more or less the same way to
give you just one example one of the
categories or the seven categories I
started speaking about back then is lots
of cells so dying and not being
automatically replaced by the division
of other cells though a simple concept
and sure enough it happens and indeed it
happens in a lot of different types of
cell in a lo different parts of the body
but in all of those cases the fix is
basically the same thing stem cell
therapy
you just put cells into the body that
you have pre-programmed into a stage
well they know what to do to divide and
to transform themselves into replacement
for the felt that the body is not
replacing like that in the body
naturally accepts this and of course
there's lots of trickery that needs to
be involved which is why this is not
necessarily working at back in 2006
several years after I mentioned that as
one of the key strategies there was a
huge breakthrough that pretty much
entirely self exactly that problem
namely the ability to create stem cells
of pretty much any type you like from
cells that were not stem cells in the
first place
in other words cells that you could take
from the person that you were going to
give them back to so you would take a
cell that wasn't even a stem cell at all
you would what often called D
differentiated back its developmental
clock to a very primitive state and then
take it back out again whatever
direction you wanted to create the kind
of stem cell that was needed for the
problem that the person had and because
it was originating from the same person
and therefore had the same DNA it would
be accepted so that's just one one part
and and back when I was talking about
all this originally that hadn't been
invented yet so it looked like it was a
much harder problem than they actually
had it would be now right but still not
hard enough to be impossible right so
these are the kind of things that
happened one of the most gratifying
aspects of the work that's happened over
the past 15 20 years since I've been
talking about this and thinking about
this is that all of the surprises the
scientific surprise we've had have been
good surprises like that we haven't had
one single case of a bad surprise there
are two kinds of bad surprise that could
have happened one is we could have come
got new types of Dan
in the body that didn't fit into my
seven-point classification and therefore
we had to come up with a whole new
different way of addressing it that
hasn't happened the other thing that
could have happened would be that one of
the existing seven categories the
approach that we were going to use to
address it we found out some reason what
would work that also hasn't happened so
and some of these other classifications
may be briefly yeah all right well
should I go next well let's take a
thorough sclerosis so atherosclerosis is
of course the number one killer in the
Western world causes heart attacks or
strokes and it happens because white
blood cells a particular type of white
blood cell called a macrophage they
don't know how to destroy a particular
compound or a particular family of
compounds but there's really only one
that has the most these compounds are
oxidized versions of cholesterol so you
all think cholesterol is a bad molecule
but it's not absolutely essential
molecule if we didn't have left it all
would be totally flat but it
spontaneously gets chemically modified
in the body into various forms that
really are bad for us
now those bad forms only are only
present at much lower abundance much
lower concentrations than regular
cholesterol but because and in
particular the cells that are affected
that really matter are these particular
types of white blood cell what happens
is that those white blood cells are
poisoned by this stuff even though it's
present rather lower buttons and they
end up being doing more harm than good
basically they end up putting out
inflammatory signals trying to get other
cells to rescue them who also can't
because they also can't buy the same
stuff and so that's where the growth of
atherosclerosis plaques comes from now
none of this would happen if these white
blood cells were able to destroy the
talking molecule because obviously if
you could destroy it it's not toxic the
question
they could we enable them to do so and
that's exactly what we succeeded in
doing the idea report forward and
actually it was almost yeah I was like
ninety that put this forward first was
to identify bacteria that have the
genetic capacity to destroy an important
toxic molecule so they would have a gene
that we don't have okay
they will have a gene that allows them
to do this now they would of course not
been doing it in order to avoid
atherosclerosis you know bacteria don't
get that but first a mother reason but
that's why we don't care why they
evolved this this works really well
you can find bacteria that can
metabolize pretty much whatever the hell
you like as long as you look in the
right place there are clever tricks for
nine whether look so sure enough we were
able to find bacteria that could
metabolize these oxidized cholesterol
derivatives now we wouldn't want to
inject those bacteria into the body but
that's not the idea the idea is to
identify the gene that they had allowed
them to do this and then put that gene
into human cells if we do that then
we're giving those cells the ability to
break down the stuff that they would not
otherwise normally naturally be able to
break down and it works we were able to
show maybe six years ago first paper
would first cut key proof of concept
paper we publish on this that works and
so you know obviously continue to push
this it should be in clinical trials
there's a company now this is all go
nicely it's not just a thorough
sclerosis so again to give illustrate
how this is just a case of
classification of problems there are
other problems other big problems
they're in the same category so this
category is basically molecular waste
products that are created as broad
products and normal metabolism and that
the cell can't destroy
okay that's the general definition of
the category another example happens in
the eye the number one cause of
blindness in the elderly is macular
degeneration and that's got nothing to
do with cholesterol but it's
fundamentally the same idea what happens
is that there are cells at the back of
the eye called retinal pigmented
epithelial cells weight accumulate a
molecule that the derivative of vitamin
A that molecule again it's only present
at relatively low abundance at first for
us it is completely resistant to any
kind of degradation by the cell so
eventually it accumulate to a point way
back in the cell and again we've
identified a bacterium and by the genes
identified be able to put that into into
himself it works and that's gonna be in
critical trials probably the theater
certainly within a year and this is the
sort of landscape of your strategies
that you that you listed there and then
this is understands Research Foundation
a nonprofit and then there's so many
other for-profit biotech aging
anti-aging companies that have could
have come up but the buck Institute is
also nonprofit well right so there's a
very much a spectrum here so technology
there's a spectrum from you know concept
to proof-of-concept to investment
product and we play a very very
important role in this we essentially
are the bridge across the valley of
death you know the valley of death in
the standard sense in which you have
come across the term you know getting
from concept to investment and the way
we do it is we identify the things that
need to be done which is obviously a
very selected subset from the basic
research discovery oriented community
that's going on in academia and we
direct money it's enterprise we can in
those projects and we get them to a
sufficient level of proof of concept
where investors at least the more
visionary investors more angel kind of
people are willing to get involved so
what we have been able to so the so the
the two examples I mentioned just now
getting rid of waste products inside the
cell versus I've been found
now you know that's what we want to do
we've done it if you look at all the
entire spectrum of what we've done we've
done that five times now there's another
one coming next month or the month after
this is our business model now so they
spin out into companies that's right we
drive we create the company in one way
or another we confer intellectual
property that we've generated into that
company and we and of course it only can
be done when investors are interested
but we talk to investors all the time
about potential products that are
projects that could be spun out into
startups and one of the most heartening
things about this is that the investors
we're talking to they tend to really
understand our model so they will very
often donate as well as invest not only
will they come and give you know seed
equity to buy equity for seed money from
these companies but also they want to be
the founding investor of the next
company so they will give us you know
respectable money purely philanthropic
ly to the foundation and what they get
for that of course is access you know
anyone who gives us a respectable amount
of money they can come visit us whenever
they like argument so yeah the situation
the financial situation in the movement
right now defined as both the nonprofit
and the for-profit is a lot healthier
than it was even a couple of years ago
but it's still got a long way to go do
not get me wrong there is no question
that it remains the case that if the
world just one more digit on the amount
of money that's available to this work
whether at the foundational stage or at
the startup stage then we could be going
two or three times as fast in terms I
mean that's a hell of a little life to
be faced
yeah so how do the these not that
nonprofits you you give the example of
what sons you will spin off and transfer
the intellectual property and that
company will go and start making money
as well and become profitable okay and
then how about all these other spin-offs
like the calicoes and Alesi ohms and all
yeah so yeah it's quite a community and
certainly we're not the only ones
spilling out companies so the buck
Institute which you mentioned a moment
ago they're a much more traditional
academic outfit they're also nonprofit
they're a bit larger than us but they
are larger than us because they've
chosen to be much more mainstream so
there's a whole bunch of things they
can't do and especially things they
can't say some of those things well
basically the aging it's bad for you you
know I mean they can't say things like
that we wait way is that that the answer
because the majority of the funding that
is received by the people that work at
the park is public money either public
money from the NIH or suchlike or it's
from foundations that are effectively
the same thing essentially from places
that have a constituency that is
abolished prorating hypnotizes you can
imagine okay now of course I can speak
to these people over a beer and totally
you know the reason why the buck and
synthesis foundation have such a close
net collaboration and we send each other
people all the time it's precisely
because there is a absolute
understanding under the radar that we're
all the same pay but there's also the
understanding that it is very valuable
to have a good cop bad cop kind of thing
where different organizations which have
identical understanding of the right
size to do that nevertheless speak to
different audiences and get money from
places now there are people give money
to the buck that would never dream of
even having you know having lunch with
me and vice versa so it's the right way
to do things
the hybrid nature of this movement it's
working well yeah it's strange that the
people that are very deep in the Pro
aging trance are are except are in many
cases giving money to buck because buck
is keeping a different profile on things
than than you are okay so how about
other the other players in the space
kind of what different kind of guys yeah
what differentiates everybody
differentiated you know the bean
companies in the anti-aging industry
forever and of course the fundamental
difficulty with those companies
[Music]
reputation you know I said when I was
getting known early on I definitely
benefit a lot from the fact that I look
a little bit unmaterialistic you know
over time the havbeen companies coming
along which have started with the best
of intentions very often they have been
started by prominent academics so there
was a company called elixir which was
started by lending around in Cynthia
Kenyon there was a company named circus
which is started by David Sinclair and
there were companies before then and
these companies you know could in
principle have done great stuff but
because they were companies and because
the people who started them didn't
really know what they were doing the
result was ended up being essentially
taken over by short term it's you know
invested and diverted into stuff that
again didn't work and so it was
essentially
we're title so the lessons have been
learned and this is not really happening
anymore
the companies are happening now are kind
of doing a bit better Elysium is a
little bit of a kind of halfway house in
the sense that it probably had a little
bit too much hype around it you know it
does have a product after all already in
the product is perhaps you know not
entirely driven but you know it's better
than Alexa was so that's that's progress
because anyone else doing the broad
scale like you were there more specialty
kind of another thing that we ecosystem
that a for-profit companies in a more
difficult position to do because we kind
of we have a remit of calico then now
calico is try and be not completely
unprintable about I don't think much of
calico essentially calico would create
and it's all Larry and Sergey fault it's
not the fault of the people at calico
Laureen so they just had a completely
[ __ ] brain-dead understanding of how
set up a company to fix a mistake okay
what do we do what company okay it's
gonna be a biotech company that's hard
the world's best biotech see ya and they
did it may be that living for the
eastern ntucky absolutely the best no
question but he actually hasn't idea how
to fix aging now the good news is that
he understands that he doesn't have to
face any how to fix eighty fine so far
unfortunately the next step is mmm have
someone who does ever do science as I
said and the problem is he also didn't
know how to do
that so he had the ultimate you know
okay what kind of sect supposed to say
that the the ultimate outcome has been
that within calico there is their own
internal valley of death right they've
got this research paradise where they'll
discover stuff until the until hell
freezes over
no and then they've got this genetic
mark to a Riverside which will take
drugs and market them really well
exactly nothing in between it's a
complete [ __ ] I mean I I have been
I've been saying this in print quite a
lot so it's okay but yeah I mean yeah
don't don't don't don't get me going
about calico in case you didn't okay he
thought you had however the rest of the
ecosystem which essentially could
this'll start ups you know it's more
startups no well I mean you no longer
small but but yeah most more times you
know that's going fine that's what I
know that's why I know that's what I'm
helping to you know to spearhead I'm you
know I spend a fantastically wonderful
amount of my time now just making
introductions between investment best
things you know just putting the right
people in touch with the right people
and getting money to flow in the right
direction in the right work done it
really makes me feel you know I don't
want to say I can see the light at the
end of the tunnel where I'm gonna be
able to you know declare victory but you
know well I'm feeling in my heart I'm
staring at the sky I thought I'd play
with that idea and you go you going
forth and doing this did that vision of
you in the art of looking up and seeing
the light stroking the beard and yeah
okay okay so so now let's talk about
what this what this is going to look
like because this is also really
important to figure out so if if I am
forty fifty and we're getting these
rejuvenations
what how does the economic and political
sociological sphere chain
so one thing I really want to do I
really really want to do in the next
like year is get in the face of proper
policymakers and opinion form it will
actually move the needle with regard to
preparation for the transition that's
going to occur the reason it's
desperately urgent is completely not
understood for a long time understood is
that people think well okay these
therapies may come along at some point
in the future but we're gonna have a lot
of warning you know there's gonna be
like a plenty of plenty of lead time
before the therapies come along we're
gonna be able to figure out what to do
people think well that's good enough you
know we're paying attention to all the
studies that are going on in my lab you
know but the fact is that's not what
policymakers and opinion formers should
be looking at yes it certainly is true
that the will be a significant lag
between the point where we have enough
proof in the laboratory that
rejuvenation is going to have good work
and the point where we actually get it
to work in humans there's plenty of like
that at least a decade sounds great but
the societal changes that are going to
occur what's gonna happen think about it
supposing you work up tomorrow morning
and you read in the papers so it wasn't
just this crazy English guy with the
beard but actually the consensus the
center of gravity of experts
gerontological opinion had become that
yes Aubrey de Grey was right all along
that you know we will get this
rejuvenation to work it's only a matter
of time that's what's gonna happen
there's going to be a point where that's
gonna happen where the literally less
than a dozen people who really control
opinion on this the the
top-level of acknowledged experts in
this area come to the conclusion but
yeah rejuvenation is going to work now
and they come to the conclusion
sufficiently strongly that they're
willing to say it on camera okay that's
the point when that happens think to
yourself what is gonna happen to you
what are you gonna do next one thing
you're gonna do is you're gonna wonder
whether your premium on your life
insurance is as low as it ought to be
you cannot think about your health
insurance because I think about
inheritance you ain't gonna think about
pensions you're gonna think about all of
the things that flow from your historic
assumption of roughly how long you're
going to live right when that day
happened there are something is going to
be turned completely upside down that
day and everybody is going to be
watching the same television on the same
day and if policymakers an opinion
formers are not ready for that need i
say more you know it's going to be
complete [ __ ] pandemonium it doesn't
matter whether it's gonna be ten years
or twenty years or a hundred years but
from that time to the point where you
actually do get these therapies working
in humans so this is completely
independent of the specter of a very
legitimate reasonable spectrum of
opinion that exists in the expert
community with regard to just how far it
is to get from life to humans completely
independent of that chaos so that's why
I'm in a hurry to talk to these people
in what would you talk to them about
what are the policies that you think are
best well they come at several levels
firstly on the research there is going
to be I mean you thought the war on
cancer would would
of a big deal you're right it wasn't
much of a big deal it was a troubling of
the you know international countries to
you budgets and it definitely made a
significant difference in the rate of
progress against cancer but it was
imperceptible today um you know the US
public as a proportion of the budget
that's not gonna be like that this is
gonna be actual wartime kind of scenario
this is gonna be a case where people are
completely not just willing but they
want to accept a substantial as required
diminution temporarily of course of
their standard of living just in order
to end the slaughter as soon as possible
okay and that will translate into policy
completely a bubble to get elected
unless you do that right but that's the
easy part
you know throwing vast amount as much
money as you can imagine or certainly as
much money is needed research and of
course there will but there are donation
we don't do that you know if at first
you couldn't find things out and get
things to work you know even the
Manhattan Project sometime right so no
so that's probably but that's the easy
part the more expensive and more
interesting part is all the other
preparation the preparation for the
point at which the therapies do come
online number one simply having the
infrastructure the number of hospitals
in the medical personnel to be able to
provide all the preventative therapy to
people who are old enough to need them
which is a lot of people right a lot
more than they already really rather
large number of people who are sick
today right because of a look at the
aging right then all the restructuring
that's got to be done in terms of
pensions as I mentioned already in
insurance and so on restructuring the
medical industry you know the industry
any industry is an ecosystem of people
who all have their own vested interests
they all need to make money you've got
to make the ecosystem work you've got to
provide the right kind of legal
structures the right kind of incentives
Reiko subsidies all this has to be
actually a you know i such work through
right and then you know i haven't begun
to and all the other stuff that we need
to figure out like
accelerating the development of things
to reduce the carbon footprint of the
average person so the overpopulation
doesn't matter or you know accelerating
the introduction of automation so that
work doesn't matter and we could forget
about pensions and so on you know
there's quite a lot and let me explain
it's not as if I claim to be an expert
on all this I'm just a recreational
demographer recreational economist you
know I'm just out there giving people
the substrate with which to do their
jobs and there's a lot of implications
for bossing just the simplest way of of
what are we gonna do with our time if we
know that we're not dying when we're 80
okay look let me explain what do we do
fact let me quote my good friend Brian
Kennedy who said this on stage when I
was like next to him and we were doing
some debate or other here I were on the
same side we were debating some bloody
philosophers someone said that kind of
thing and he said well look if I've got
the choice of being born at age 150 or
going outside with an age 80 I think I
know which one I'm going to choose and I
think I know which one you're going to
choose to I mean and in is from this is
this is from this from the idea that I
was coming out of when are we gonna have
when are we gonna choose to have kids
we're not gonna need to have children
until later work we're gonna have more
time I'm not saying these questions are
infantile of course they're sensible the
problem is that people actually get hung
up on the questions yes absolutely it
would be nice to think about and
speculate about how often we'd have kids
and you know what when we're doing one
time it one could but all one time
staring at the sky from one thought
tough more time to be creative and start
more business you don't say